This is gonna be in a simulator.
I'm just gonna set that
expectation at the start.
If you clicked on this thinking that
someone had miraculously
given an idiot
an actual jumbo jet to land...
No, this is a simulator.
But this is Petter from
Mentour Pilot,
who is a qualified pilot and
qualified training instructor, right?
Yes, correct.
I work with instructing new pilots
and examining new pilots
before they're allowed to
actually fly the real aircraft,
and after they're allowed
to fly the real aircraft as well.
And so over on your channel,
you are gonna be doing the breakdown
of everything you are
about to tell me
from your air traffic control
centre through there.
Exactly. That's the idea.
Yeah, you're not gonna be
in there with me.
I'm gonna be on my own
in the disaster movie scenario
where I am the only one
left conscious on the plane.
And... I dunno, what do you
think my odds are?
I'd say they're pretty good.
I'd say in the
high 20 percentile, yeah.
Right, okay.
But in order for me to know that,
really, I need to know:
Do you have any previous
experience at all?
I've been in one flight simulator
for a Comic Relief video
many, many years ago.
But they just put us on
the easiest version.
We were already coming in
to land, and it was just:
keep the controls straight,
you'll be fine.
This is a motion based simulator.
It's gonna move.
Yeah.
Which we have been given for free
for the whole day
in exchange for me saying that
this is the brand new
Airline Flight Academy
Simulator Centre in Dublin,
with six state of the art flight simulators
that provides top class training services,
including B737 and A320 type ratings
and industry leading APS MCC courses.
(inhale) There we go.
Excellent. Well done.
Alright.
Next time I see you,
I will have either landed or...
...landed the hard way.
Correct. And I'm gonna
go this way.
Thank you! (wheezes)
Okay, I'm in position.
Seatbelt on.
I guess this is the first cheat,
which is that I would never have got
through that cockpit door, right?
Absolutely.
So we have to do this
as a theoretical scenario
where you have gotten access
to the cockpit in some fashion.
But in reality,
in an emergency like this,
a passenger would never get access
through the closed cockpit door.
And would never be able to magically
conjure up an air traffic controller
on their headset immediately.
In this case, obviously we are
communicating through handhelds,
because you are in a simulator
and I'm in a briefing room,
and this is the only way
we could do it.
Yeah, that's fair enough.
Alright.
We are on autopilot at 15,000 feet.
Let's land this thing.
What I want to try to establish now
is basically where you are,
and then we're going to discuss
how we are gonna get you
down on the ground safely.
So if you could see at the
top of that display,
there should be a box with
three green values in it.
Something like N1, hopefully LNAV,
and something else.
Can you say to me what it says
in those three values at the top?
Yes, I can.
Left is MCP[Mike Charlie Papa] SPD[Sierra Papa Delta].
Middle is LNAV.
Right is ALT HOLD.
Perfect. That means that you're
maintaining the altitude now.
And remember that the autopilot
that you've just confirmed is on
is like a third crew member.
That's the way that we pilots view it.
That crew member is perfectly
capable of flying this aircraft.
So what we're gonna do
from now on is
we're going to try to tell
that autopilot what to do,
in order to get you safely
down on the ground, okay?
Understood, and we're aiming for
Dublin Airport, is that right?
Yeah, I have you on radar here,
and it looks like you're
pretty close to Dublin Airport.
So that's what
we're going to try to do.
Now, the top— If you look
below the glare shield,
the top panel below the glare shield,
it's called a mode control panel.
It has a lot of windows with numerical
figures in them and a lot of buttons.
Do you know which panel
I'm talking about?
I believe so.
That would be directly below
the windscreen, the windshield.
Yeah, that's correct.
That panel controls the autopilot.
Okay?
You will see on the right-hand side
that there is one button
that says CMD [Charlie Mike Delta],
and it would be green. Confirm.
Confirmed.
Yeah, that's the autopilot button.
Do not press that because that
disconnects the autopilot,
and that will be a very bad day.
(wheezing)
Understood.
Not touching that button.
(laughs) Okay.
If you can find the window
that says Altitude on it.
Tell me when you've seen it.
I see it. It reads 15,000.
Yeah. Just below that,
there is a knob.
Can you turn that knob
until the value reads
4,000 feet instead?
Confirmed.
That now reads 4,000.
The wheels next to
what I assume is the throttle
just started spinning
on their own,
and the plane is now banking
very, very, very heavily to the left.
Yeah, that's because
it's following
the LNAV track that it has
pre-programmed.
Don't worry about that.
Okay, so the aircraft is now
descending down to 4,000 feet.
That's what we've told it,
and it's now following,
heading 2-7-0,
so we're good, right.
The aircraft is doing exactly what
it's supposed to do,
and what we wanna figure out now is
how much time we have to do this.
So in the screen that is
second from the left,
in the right hand corner there,
there should be a value of
how much fuel in total
that you have on board.
Can you read that out to me?
Yep. Confirm total 3.8.
3.8, okay, that's perfect.
So that's quite a lot of fuel.
So we have plenty of time.
Alright. So time is not an issue.
From now on, it's gonna start to be
a little bit more complicated, okay?
Because now we have the
aircraft on the controls.
So now we're gonna try
to get it into position
from which it can auto-land.
So first of all, I want you
to get your seat adjusted,
where you can rest your feet
on the pedals easily.
If this is an ejector seat,
I'm gonna kill him!
Yep, okay, I'm in position.
Alright, so what we need
to do now is,
you're going way too fast, okay?
We need to get your speed back
in order to make a safe landing.
So if you go up to the
mode control panel again,
and you go out to the left side,
the second window from the left
should read IAS or Mach.
Can you tell me again what
the number is in that window?
2-9-1.
Okay, that means that you're flying
291 knots at the moment.
Can you bring that value
back to 220 knots?
2-2-0 confirmed.
Perfect.
(C major tone)
Can you just tell me if
the speed is reducing?
No, it's not. There was also
just a very loud beep
that sounded like a dial tone
for about two seconds.
You can disregard that for now.
That's because you are about
to level off at your altitude.
That's good. Okay.
The speed is not decreasing.
We're still at 262.
Well, if you're at 262,
and you were at 293,
then it is reducing.
Oh yeah, I'm just
nearly panicking slightly.
I forgot this was a simulator
for a minute.
Okay, good.
Now we're gonna turn you,
turn the aircraft again.
So if you go back up to the
mode control panel
and look at the
heading window again.
Yep. Currently reading 270.
Okay, can you turn
that knob below that
to the left until you get
a number of 100 on it?
100 confirmed.
The plane immediately started
banking heavily to the left.
Yeah, that's exactly
what we wanted to do.
'Cause what I'm doing now
is I'm actually
turning you downwind
for the landing, okay?
I cannot overstate
how unnerving it is
to be in a motion-based simulator
for the first time in my life.
It is so convincing!
Yeah, no, that's the idea.
Right, so you are currently
maintaining 4,000 feet,
and can you tell me what speed
you're keeping at the moment?
2-1-9.
Now you are coming almost perfectly
abeam the airfield now, which is great.
So the next thing that
I want you to do is,
to the right of the thrust levers,
there is a flap lever.
Do you see that?
I see it.
I want you to move that flap lever
to the five position.
If you have to go through a gate,
first one, and then
you can move it to five.
Yep. That caused the
trim wheels to spin, a lot.
Yeah, so what's happening
now is that the flaps,
those things at the back of the wings,
they're now extending.
That's causing a lot of drag
and a lot of shift
in the way that
the aircraft needs to fly.
So that's why the trims are moving.
They're trying to readjust to
this new configuration.
But this also allows us
to reduce the speed.
So if you go back up to
the speed selector.
Yep.
Bring that back to 180 knots.
1-8-0. I can actually feel us
slowing down in here.
Yeah. Yep.
That's what we want.
So now we're in a
really good position, okay.
The flaps are coming out.
The radials are all set up.
And basically, I'm just waiting to
turn you in for final now.
Okay, I could briefly see
the ocean below me, so...
Knowing Dublin Airport, I'm guessing
I'm doing a right turn soon, I think.
Correct, correct.
But we're gonna take you,
we're gonna take you out quite far,
so that you have a long final.
The other thing that we need
to discuss is after landing,
the only thing that this aircraft
will not be able to do automatically
is to maintain the direction
once it's on the ground.
You will have to do that
using your feet, okay?
Okay.
The thing to remember is that you
don't need to push almost anything,
especially not at high speed.
It's just basically a light
squeeze left to right,
If you see that it's deviating
from the centre line.
It probably won't, but if it does,
that's all you need to do.
So basically let the plane
do everything until we're down,
at which point,
slight touches on the pedals
to make sure we keep towards
the centre line of the runway.
Correct.
Alright, let's land this.
Confirmed that we
are pitching downwards.
Altitude is decreasing.
Perfect. Perfect.
That's exactly what—
Now you're captured on the
glide slope and the localizer.
So now we're well set up.
Now the next thing
that you need to do is...
I can see the runway.
If you go up to those autopilot
buttons that I talked about.
You can see those four ones at the
top-right part of the mode control panel.
Yes, I see it. A/P Engage.
Also, I have visual on the runway.
The next thing we wanna do is
we want to reduce the speed
back to landing speed.
So if you take the flap selector
and bring it all the way
back to flap 40.
Flap 40. Got it.
We just had the
2,500 announcement.
Lot of trim happening.
Yeah, because the flaps are
extending to its full position,
so that's perfectly normal.
As we now get a little bit lower,
I want you to monitor the
flight mode annunciator,
those three green bars
on the top,
and just tell me if something
appears there, something different.
Alright, we've just got green
letters at the moment.
I'll let you know if anything changes.
One hundred.
Perfect. What I'm looking for
is something called flare.
It should say flare,
but it'll come later on.
Minimums.
Flare and minimums
were just called.
Remember now that
once the aircraft touches down,
which is gonna do by itself,
once that's happening,
then you are the one that's going to
control it on the ground with the rudders.
So don't do any big adjustments,
very small, smooth
adjustments on the runway,
and just let it come to
a complete stop, okay?
One thousand.
Understood, just passed
through one thousand,
and I've got the Dublin smokestacks
over to the left of me.
Alright.
Here goes.
Okay, can you see 'Flare'
annunciated on the...
on the primary flight display,
on the FMA?
Yeah, I have 'Flare' on
the display in front of me.
Perfect, that means that the aircraft
knows that it's gonna do an auto-land.
So that's good news.
There are cars on the roads
in this simulator!
I just wanna tell you, good luck.
We're all counting on you.
I mean, we're counting on
the autopilot at this point,
but I'll take it.
Yeah, you're getting close now, man.
Very close.
I'm just gonna keep my
feet resting on the pedals.
Ready for arrival.
We are at 300 feet.
Here we go.
Let me know when the aircraft
has gone to a complete stop.
I feel like I should be
holding this,
and that's not my job.
The computer's doing everything.
I just need to just stay back,
do not touch anything
until we're down.
There we go.
Fifty.
50 feet.
Forty.
Thirty.
Twenty.
Ten.
Flaring.
There we go. We're good.
Little bit of, little bit to the right,
little bit to the right.
Little bit to the right.
(softly) Oh, let's hope that
he comes to a stop!
Come on, Tom. There we are.
The aircraft is at a complete stop.
We have landed.
(wheezing)
(slow, hearty clapping)
(chuckling)
My man, Tom!
Thank you so, so much.
Welcome to Dublin.
(sputtering)
(laughing)
I mean, the computer
did everything.
It was knowing what to push
and having the confidence
to know what to push.
Yeah.
But you see how well this aircraft
does things when you just tell it.
That's what I meant by
having a third crew member.
Absolutely.
If you just communicate,
if I communicate to you,
and you communicate to that,
it works perfectly.
And what if there was like
strong crosswinds,
weather, anything like that?
It would handle it
up to a certain amount.
But I wouldn't take you in
if the crosswind was too hard.
Right.
But the problem with
higher crosswind would've been
to stay on the centre line
of the landing,
which is why I was
briefing about that—
Oh yeah, we kept going
to the left,
and I kept pushing more
on the right.
But you're here,
and you're on the ground.
This is exactly where we
want you, on the asphalt.
(group laughing)
So cool, man. Well done.
Thank you.
Well done.
Okay, after the break,
I'm gonna try that
without the autopilot.
If you are looking for a new career,
then you might want to look at
learning to code with
this video's sponsor, Boolean.
They're a career focused tech academy
with live online classes,
and now's the time to apply to
their final cohort of the year,
which starts on November 7th.
Boolean's courses last between
ten weeks and six months,
full-time or part-time.
You can choose between
front end development,
full-stack, or data analytics.
And those courses are
designed to start a career.
They focus on practical work,
and their teachers are people
with industry experience
who've done the job,
not just learned the theory.
You can have a look at testimonials
from previous students on their site,
and they also have a refund guarantee.
If you complete the course,
apply to jobs, and don't get hired,
they'll refund you.
Or you can choose to pay afterwards
when you actually get hired.
So if you are seriously considering
taking the next step in your career
and joining a fast-growing
industry like tech,
you may want to consider signing up
for Boolean's last cohort of the year.
And if you mention that you found out
about them from me, when you apply,
they'll also give you a
£500 discount.
There's a link down in
the description.
Good luck for your future.
And as for my future...
well, it's time to
turn off the autopilot.
Okay, a few upgrades and
a few very much downgrades.
I've got a push-to-talk button
down here now,
so I don't need to keep reaching up
to a microphone to touch things.
But also the very first thing
we're gonna do,
as soon as the sim sets off,
is turn off the autopilot.
Wish me luck.
Okay. Ready when you are.
Okay. So on your...
If you hold onto the steering yoke
on your right hand side,
there is a button by
your right thumb.
Do you find it?
The one that says
Autopilot Disengage?
The very same, yes.
Shall I push it?
When you push it, you're gonna have
a terrifying siren going off,
telling you that it's just
you and me now.
So press it once,
and when that siren goes off,
press it again
to get rid of the siren.
(klaxon-like buzzing)
(buzzing stops)
Confirmed. We are on manual.
Now, we're gonna concentrate
more or less on
what you see on your
primary flight display.
That's the screen that is
straight in front of you.
So what speed are you
keeping at the moment?
2-2-4.
Okay, now what
I want you to do is
I want you to bring back
the thrust levers a little bit.
Bring them back a little bit
and feel what happens
to the aircraft when it does so.
Feel that it's trying to
pitch forward by itself.
Can you feel that?
Yes, I can.
Alright, pitch it forward,
but not too much.
Just a couple of degrees.
And you'll see on the horizon,
you know,
the altitude indicator,
that you have a cross
in front of you.
Just bring it down
a couple of degrees,
but don't let the speed
decrease too much, okay?
Just keep the speed going around
the speed that you have now.
Understood. It's less of a cross and
more of a T-shape at this point.
I appear to be descending quite rapidly.
I'm gonna pull back a little on the stick.
(C major tone)
That's it, okay.
That warning that
you just heard is that
you're away from
your cleared altitude,
but we're gonna disconnect—
disregard that completely now.
Okay. I'm holding the speed
at about 1-9-8.
We are descending.
(C major tone)
If the speed is 190,
you're too slow.
So pitch forward a little bit.
When you say pitch forward,
does that mean
go down or go up?
That means go down.
It means push your yoke
away from you.
So push it, but very little.
Remember, it's a
big aircraft, this.
So just push it forward
a little bit, okay?
And on your left-hand thumb,
you have a trim switch.
That's the one that moves
those little wheels next to you.
That's, if you feel that you need to use
a lot of force when you're flying,
you need to move that switch
either forward or backwards
to get that force away, right.
You're trimming out the aircraft,
making it easier for you to fly.
Do you mean right thumb?
It might be, yeah, it might be
on your right thumb, I checked.
You're actually in the first officer's
seat, so that makes sense.
Can you see them?
Try them.
Move them forward and see
if those little wheels move.
Got it.
Okay, so use those.
If you feel that the forces
are being too much,
then use them to either go
forward or backwards
in order to feel better,
basically.
I'm not gonna tell you
how to do it.
You're gonna have to
find that out yourself.
Right turn please.
So bank to the right.
Turn right a little bit.
Confirming, banking right,
20 degrees.
Perfect. That's it.
Okay, how's your speed doing?
2-2-3.
Perfect.
Passing through 5,000 feet.
Yep, I can see you,
and I can see that you're turning
as well, so that's good.
Now what I would like you to do
is add a little bit of thrust
and just feel how the aircraft
feels different when you do so.
Add a bit of thrust and feel how
that pushes the nose upwards.
That's just to prepare you for
what's gonna happen later on
when we get onto the approach.
Yep. Understood.
Increased thrust.
Yep. So keep the speed.
This time you can set the speed
to about 190 knots, okay?
You with me?
Speed— Okay, hang on.
I need to level this out.
Speed is 2-0-8.
Had a bit of a panic there,
but I think I've levelled it out.
Perfect, alright.
So take the thrust off again
and continue to descend.
We want you down to
4,000 feet.
I have no idea whether
I'm going up or down
unless I check the instrument
display in front of me.
That's the only thing you have.
You need to look in front of you.
At the moment, you are
descending again,
but very slowly, so you can take
a little bit more thrust off.
So bring the thrust levels back and
we're going down to 4,000 feet.
That's 1,000 feet to go.
4,800.
Perfect. Now I want you
to turn left, okay, left.
And try to hit a heading
of 240 degrees,
240 degrees. Got it.
Where the hell
do I see my heading?
Yeah, so the heading is right below
your primary flight display, right?
If you look at that cross
you have in front of you,
if you'll go straight below that,
you'll see your heading.
Confirmed, currently reading...
Currently reading 360.
Turn left onto a heading of
180 degrees initially.
We're just gonna have
to stabilise here
before we get in
for the approach.
Heading is 2-4-2.
I am quite happy with how
I came outta that turn,
if I'm honest with you.
I won't be smug for too long,
but I'm happy with that.
Yeah, that's good.
Now you're getting a little bit too
close to the airport though,
so I want you to continue
that left hand turn
to heading of like
150 degrees, okay?
Oh yeah, we were aiming
for 180, weren't we?
And I stopped at 240.
That's me being an idiot.
Repeat the heading
you want, please.
Put a heading of 150 degrees.
Aiming for 1-5-0.
Have passed 4,000 feet.
I'm gonna try and stabilise.
That's fine.
Actually, if we can get you down
to 3,000 feet, it's even better.
Continuing to 3,000 feet,
aiming for 1-8-0.
Speed steady at 2-2-3.
Okay, can you turn right,
heading 2-4-0 degrees?
Heading right, 2-4-0 degrees,
confirmed.
Staying at speed 1-9-2.
I've gone up to 3,500 feet again,
and I didn't even notice.
Don't worry, get yourself down again,
but make that right turn now,
because we need you to
align with the final.
If you look out to your left, you have
your navigation display there.
You should be able to see
the runway there.
That will tell you
something to aim for, okay?
2,500 feet. I'm pulling up.
Okay, can you just read out what
it says on your FMA please?
Standby, flying!
(chuckles)
You're doing great.
You're doing great, Tom.
Yeah, I think I'm yawing
up and down a lot here.
Yeah, I can imagine.
It's not an easy aircraft to fly,
this, so you're doing great.
Okay.
Make sure you don't turn
too much to the right, okay?
You're on a heading of
2-9-0 degrees now,
so just keep that diamond
in the centre.
I just noticed that I turned
completely the wrong way.
That was me being an idiot.
No, no. Just keep that
diamond in the centre, right?
It'll tell you what to do.
The idea is that you are
supposed to be with—
Do you see that white
rectangle in the middle?
That's you.
And if that's in the middle of
that cross, then you are bang on.
Okay? That's what
you're looking for.
The diamond is
way off to the left.
Do I need to steer left or right?
If the diamond is to the left,
you need to turn to the left.
Confirmed, doing that now.
Small corrections.
I know it's small corrections.
I'm just not making
small corrections,
because I'm panicking,
because this is—
So you need to turn left now.
Understood!
This is extremely convincing.
There's so much to
keep track of.
I have a glide slope diamond!
Okay.
Try to get yourself back
on the localizer, okay?
'Cause I think you're a little bit
off on the right hand side.
So you might've turned
a bit left.
Now when you hit
the glide slope diamond,
when that comes into middle,
then bring the thrust levels
back to about 50%.
Okay, I have visual
on the runway!
Okay, what's the diamond
on the right-hand side doing?
It is dead level.
Okay, start pitching down.
Pitch down to
about a little bit minus.
You wanna descend with
about 800 feet per minute.
Understood.
I'm not on the ILS.
I can't see the—
I'm several degrees off here.
Okay, but you see the runway.
Just point for the runway
at this point.
If you're visual, point for
the runway and keep descending.
Now what we need to do is you
need to turn, put the gear down.
Okay? Put the gear down.
Gear is going down.
Bring the flaps to 15.
Flaps to 15.
Repeat what you said
about thrust earlier, please.
Yeah, bring the thrust back.
And if you look at your
engine instrumentation
— that's on the third screen,
on your left —
at the very top there,
put the N1 value to 53%.
Where the hell's the
N1 value?!
Don't matter. Don't matter.
Pitch down.
You're too high now.
Can you see the runway still?
Yes, I can still see the runway.
Can you see if there's a
couple of lights
on the left-hand side?
White or red?
All white! All white!
I know I need
two white, two red.
Yeah. So pitch down,
take thrust off to idle, okay?
This is not a good angle to
be coming into a runway from.
This is not good. This is not good.
This is not good.
Okay, so how is it looking?
Are you descending?
Not good!
He's too— He's too high.
Keep descending, okay?
And I think you're levelling.
You're quite aligned
with the runway now.
Keep descending, bring
the flaps back to 30, please.
Keep the thrust at idle
and keep descending
until you get at least one red.
When you do that,
start pitching up.
I have two white lights
and two red lights.
I'm gonna try and hold it there.
That's perfect.
So the thrust should
come up a little bit now,
because if you're taking flaps 40 and
you don't have any thrust, it's going to stall.
So bring the thrust up
to about midway.
Understood!
1,000 feet!
Okay, you have the gear down
and the flaps to 30, confirm.
Confirmed.
Okay, just aim at the
very beginning of the runway.
Now, when you get
over the runway,
close the thrust levers and
keep the altitude, more or less.
Let it just sink down
on the runway itself.
Once you land, you have to use those
brakes at the top of your feet, okay?
The brakes to stop it.
Otherwise it will not stop.
I'm aiming for the taxiway.
There's no way I can hit the runway.
Glideslope. Glideslope.
Okay, if you have a nice, long
straight ahead of you,
then use that and just make sure that
you set it down on the asphalt, okay?
Glideslope. Glideslope.
Glideslope.
Breathe.
Twenty. Ten.
No!
(tinny explosion noises)
And that was a crash.
Yeah. Yeah.
I'm sorry, man.
Ah, it was— I—
There was just so many
things at the end there.
Whew! (hooting)
Oh, thank you for trying!
Well, we got you...
Did you crash on the runway
or in the airport vicinity at least?
I was lined up what I think was
pretty well for a taxiway.
Like, I tried to
square it up at the end.
Didn't quite get it, but I had a
taxiway in front of me,
and then I just tried to brake
and flare and everything,
and it just hit way too hard.
Yeah, right, right.
Yeah, yeah.
But at least you happened
on the airport perimeter,
which means that you have emergency
services and everything there,
which is pretty much the best we
could expect from this kind of situation.
So, well done.
I'll take that.
Thank you very much, Petter.
[Caption+ by JS*
caption.plus | @caption_plus]
More than welcome.